[Musique]
sensation sensation le mag bonjour à
tous bienvenue sur sensation en
association avec TV 78 le 13 mai
prochain l'association lipsart vous
propose un récital de musique classique
en forêt de Rambouillet ça s'appelle le
silence de la forêt et pour en parler
avec nous je reçois aujourd'hui Stéphane
1 trésorier de l'IPSA bonjour alors on
va parler justement de l'événement avant
ça j'aimerais qu'on s'arrête un petit
peu plus sur l'association elle a été
créée fin 2021 donc c'est une
association récente qu'est-ce qui a
conduit à la création de l'ipsart quel
est son histoire alors il a été créée à
l'initiative donc du président actuel
qui s'appelle Philippe Nizou qui est élu
à la culture dans la commune des
Bréviaires et donc je l'ai aidé pour
monter je suis co-fondateur je l'ai aidé
pour monter effectivement cette cette
association et le but était de pouvoir
avoir des moyens et les mains un peu
libres pour créer des animations
culturelles autour du territoire des
bréviseurs et du Sud Yvelines et comment
est-elle évoluée justement en à peine
deux ans
elle a évolué par l'organisation de
spectacle musicaux pour pour la plupart
par par des rencontres je reviendrai
peut-être tout à l'heure sur ce qu'on a
déjà organisé des récits de chansons
avec Claude Lemelle en particulier
on essaye aussi d'aider d'autres
associations donc en collaboration pour
monter des pièces de théâtre qu'on a
fait avec le Lion's Club de Rambouillet
on a monté également un tour de champ
concernant Joe Dassin avec notre
association qui s'appelle Paris musique
voilà donc on essaye d'effectivement de
de promouvoir des concerts d'artistes
alors des fois locaux si possible locaux
mais l'artiste qui va venir d'un peu
plus loin si le faut mais le tout c'est
d'animer le tissu culturel local lipsart
c'est pas seulement donc des des
concerts ou des pièces de théâtre c'est
vraiment tout toute la culture
finalement dans son ensemble que vous
voulez valoriser absolument c'est
l'ensemble de la culture bon pour
l'instant effectivement on a plutôt
organisé des des concerts et des pièces
de théâtre mais on a également ouvert
une souscription pour un
tableau de Benjamin Huan qui s'appelle
le labourage qui a un tableau local qui
a été retrouvé un peu par hasard dans un
grenier au bréviaire et donc qui a été
restauré et qui vient d'être installé à
la mairie des Brévières par exemple
voilà donc le l'éventail est assez large
alors on peut pas toujours tout
organiser pour une exposition ça prend
un petit peu de temps il faut de la
place donc il faut pouvoir aller locaux
pour ça mais effectivement on essaie de
couvrir l'ensemble de la culture alors
est-ce que d'une manière générale
Rambouillet ou même le département des
Yvelines et
briève c'est ça non
est-ce que justement c'est ces deux
territoires sont sans force de
proposition en termes de d'artistes
locaux alors le territoire de
Rambouillet c'est surtout donc centré se
Rambouillet il y a un pôle assez
important là-bas alors des artistes
locaux il y en a quelques-uns mais il y
en a pas de temps que cela donc pour
pouvoir faire tourner une médiathèque
comme celle de Rambouillet il faut quand
même avoir des des artistes un peu
connus dernièrement il y a Charlie
Winston qui est venu à Rambouillet donc
nous c'est pareil effectivement on
essaye de pouvoir organiser des
événements avec des locaux mais ils sont
pas forcément non plus très connus donc
on essaie plutôt de les insérer dans un
programme un peu plus global avec des
gens un petit peu plus connus de manière
à faire un peu un mix de voilà pour
pouvoir attirer du monde surtout l'idée
justement c'est ça c'est de de de
valoriser les artistes locaux parce que
en tout cas actuellement ils sont
parfois pas assez valorisés
c'est à dire c'est une question de
d'opportunité pour le nerf de la guerre
c'est de se faire connaître on peut
avoir du talent ça c'est une chose il
faut en avoir mais le nerf de la guerre
c'est de se faire connaître il faut
qu'après que les gens puissent venir les
découvrir donc toute la toute la
problématique elle a quoi en définitive
et le 13 mai prochain donc vous
valorisez le projet le silence de la
forêt à récital de musique classique en
forêt de Rambouillet la table du roi par
Olivia gay et Célia Oneto Bensaid ce
n'est pas un lieu très commun pour un
récital et pourtant vous avez choisi ce
lieu pourquoi alors ce déjà le silence
de la forêt est un programme de récital
qui est organisé par par Olivia gay
c'est une violence et liste un peu
militante écologiste on va dire mais au
bon sens du terme elle a vraiment à cœur
de pouvoir organiser de jouer en forêt
en communion on va dire avec la nature
avec les arbres donc ça c'est voilà
c'est son mantra donc on en a fait la
connaissance d'Olivia et on lui a
proposé effectivement un lieu
supplémentaire en forêt Rambouillet qui
est la table du roi la table de roi
c'est l'endroit où Louis XVI prenait ses
repas avant et après avoir fait les
séchasses on va dire donc c'est un lieu
connu et remarquable à quelques
centaines de mètres des étangs de
Hollande quoi c'est c'est finalement un
lieu historique mais aussi à découvrir
notamment à travers à travers l'art
voilà exactement c'est à découvrir c'est
une petite voilà c'est un croisement de
un croisement de route forestière avec
une table en pierre et quelques
tabourets en pierre on va dire dans un
lieu un lieu historique à découvrir et
ce récital sera rythmé donc par la
violence et liste Olivia gay mais aussi
la pianiste Célia Oneto Bensaid alors
qui sont un petit peu ces deux artistes
donc c'est
donc Olivia je viens d'évoquer un petit
peu c'est une violence et liste qui a
fait le conservatoire de Belfort de
Strasbourg et puis après Paris et donc
en partenariat avec l'Office National
des Forêts l' ONF auquel on va
d'ailleurs un fond de soutien auquel on
va reverser une grosse partie des
bénéfices de la de de l'événement alors
elle organisée déjà ce manifestation du
silence de la forêt du côté de
Fontainebleau il y en aura d'autres et
donc voilà c'est quelqu'un c'est une
violence qui commence à être connu qui a
fait un certain nombre de qui a fait de
deux ou trois albums déjà et donc qui
est très orienté musique et écologique
et
Célia honnête au Bensaid bon c'est une
pianiste de 30 ans Olivia 36 ans Célia
30 ans donc ils sont jeunes et qui a
fait le Conservatoire de Paris qui
commence aussi à être connu à faire des
la fin ou des albums et voilà ce sont
des des jeunes pousses de la musique
voilà en pleine en plein devenir et pour
se donner une idée plus précise on va
écouter un extrait de d'Olivier Gates
son violoncelle et on poursuit juste
après
[Musique]
Olivia gay donc à retrouver ce 13 mai à
la forêt de Rambouillet on imagine que
les places se sont limitées on l'a déjà
évoqué mais pourquoi est-ce qu'il est
intéressant de découvrir ce récital dans
une forêt qu'est-ce que qu'est-ce que ce
lieu apporte alors déjà c'est un lieu
quand même très atypique
et le but c'est d'avoir vraiment une
communion entre la musique et la nature
qui entoure
une certaine atmosphère bien sûr
Silvestre mais avec cette musique qui va
s'inscrire s'inscrire dans dans le lieu
dans le décor donc voilà c'est de
pouvoir éprouver des sensations
particulières qu'on n'aurait pas
forcément dans une salle classique mais
le projet donc s'appelle le silence de
la forêt il est porté hein justement par
par la violence et liste Olivia gay vous
vous le soutenez vous organiser un cet
événement est-ce que c'est un événement
qui pourrait être reconduit notamment
avec d'autres artistes ah bah tout à
fait effectivement le concept pour être
reconduit avec d'autres artistes à
condition que c'est un sens
artistiquement bien évidemment
je tiens d'ailleurs à que si la mairie
des Bréviaires et son maire chaque
fromentique qui nous aide logistiquement
énormément dans toutes nos démarches et
donc il sera aussi présent en tant que
co-organisateur de l'événement parce que
c'est sur son territoire des Bréviaires
quoi alors on va parler des projets des
futurs projets pour l'année 2023 quels
sont les autres événements que que vous
allez organiser alors on a prévu au mois
d'octobre un concert
un concert en hommage à Michel Delpech
c'est un de un de ses amis on va dire
intime mythique qui s'appelle Michel
Pollet qui a commencé je dirais à être
accompagné déjà d'un chauffeur au départ
qui est un ami d'Alain Chamfort et en
plus il y a après il a rencontré Michel
Delpech il a écrit pas mal de chansons
pour lui
ainsi le Loir-et-Cher par exemple etc
mais il a également composé pour Dave
pour Philippe Laville Jean-Luc Lahaye
d'autres voilà donc c'est et donc il a
avec un groupe d'amis on sait que
quelqu'un d'un certain âge maintenant
mais avec un groupe il a un spectacle de
près qui va qui rend hommage à Michel
Delpech et donc là on se donne
rendez-vous du coup pour le pour le mois
d'octobre pour le mois d'octobre
absolument on imagine car récital dans
une forêt ne s'organise pas du jour au
lendemain quels ont été justement les
étapes pour pouvoir organiser cet
événement alors il faut être le faire
déjà prendre contact avec Olivia gay
verrouiller les dates etc
mettre en place bon on a on a des sites
internet effectivement qui décrivent
l'événement donc mettant mettre en place
l'habilletterie voir avec l'ONF de
manière à préparer les lieux avant le
concert après il y a toute une
logistique sur place parce que bon il
faudra aiguiller les gens les faire
garder les voitures près des étendoland
à certains endroits avoir des bénévoles
qui les conduisent qui les amènent
jusqu'à au lieu lui-même parce que c'est
à plusieurs centaines de mètres dans la
forêt donc non accessible directement en
voiture après il y a toute la logistique
les chaises les toilettes enfin bon j'en
parle c'est un voilà c'est un événement
à découvrir et qui risque de justement
nous donner de bien belles surprises
merci beaucoup Stéphane d'avoir été avec
nous sur sensation donc je rappelle que
le silence de la forêt ça se passe le 13
mai à la table du roi en forêt de
Rambouillet on peut retrouver toutes les
informations d'accès de billetterie sur
le site eloasso.com et pour revoir ou
réécouter cette émission rendez-vous sur
notre site et notre application radio
sensation
[Musique]